el sahara occidental- estuvo bajo la
soberanía española desde la década de
1880 hasta mediados de 1970 después de
la retirada de españa marruecos se anexó
alrededor de dos tercios del territorio
pero los marroquíes se enfrentaron con
la feroz resistencia de un grupo armado
que pidió la independencia de la región
en 1976 el frente polisario declaró la
creación de la república árabe saharaui
democrática el conflicto que duró
décadas volvió a estallar en 2020
después de que se estancará las
negociaciones de la onu mientras que el
frente polisario acusa a españa de
eludir sus responsabilidades como
antigua potencia colonial y de no ayudar
activamente a la onu a organizar un
referendo sobre el autodeterminación
marruecos por otro lado no dude en
reaccionar si alguien intenta socavar su
reclamo sobre la tierra en disputa el
mes pasado el ministerio de relaciones
exteriores en rabat advirtió que habría
consecuencias después de que madrid
dejara que el líder del frente polisario
ibrahim ghali recibiera tratamiento
hospitalario y en españa el año pasado
cuando alemania criticó a eeuu
por respaldar a rabat marruecos retiro
al embajador alemán de su país y cortó
lazos con las instituciones culturales
de la nación europea españa está
interesada en mantener relaciones
positivas con su vecino del sur debido
al potencial económico y la posición
estratégica del país norteafricano los
dos también comparten fronteras
terrestres los únicos cruces de este
tipo entre la unión europea y un país
africano son ceuta y melilla vestigios
de la colonización española y portuguesa
del siglo 15 son dos enclaves rodeados
por marruecos por un lado y el mar
mediterráneo por el otro rabat ha
exigido durante mucho tiempo el control
de las dos ciudades pero sus esfuerzos
han sido inútiles